hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
how is this pandemic changing our
politics is there going back to normal
and so many say they want and what about
the surveillance state are they the only
ones who benefit from all of this to
discuss this and more I'm joined by my
guest referee Nash ah in Reston she is
the founder and CEO of Loom global
partners as well as adviser to vote run
lead in perth amboy we have rich Cassell
though he is a political strategist in
tech CEO and in percival we have Ned
Ryan he is founder and CEO of American
majority as well as author of the new
book restoring our Republic all right
crosstalk rules in effect that means you
can jump in anytime you want and I
always appreciate let me go to you net
here is the most fundamental question as
we go through this crisis is how is it
changing our politics in a kind of in a
microwave in a macro in a microwave is
the Democratic primary essentially
has been put into deep freeze maybe be
canceled they talking about not having
kin conventions and maybe putting
pressure on the Republicans not to do
the same thing we've never been in these
waters before but also how people feel
about how the authorities are reacting
to it because when you look at the the
bailout or stimulus whatever you want to
call it it's pretty flattened Leo being
some folks and it's helping not helping
a whole lot of other folks so kind of
give us the macro micro is we're kind of
managing navigating ourselves through
all this yeah no Peter I think you're
right I think there are a couple
different levels to all of this how it's
changing politics I'll tell you from
experience American majority action
right now our work in Wisconsin has
changed dramatically we focus a lot on
conversations live door knocks and
conversations on doorsteps those are not
happening those have have disappeared
and we've had to go to more peer-to-peer
texting and live phone calls more
impersonal voter contact there's been a
lot of absentee ballot requests people
are requesting those so they don't have
to go vote in person you know so those
elections are next week in Wisconsin and
I think you're gonna see more and more
of that as
is out you're starting to see a drumbeat
from many they want to see the fall
elections move to more mail-in voting
which you know of course I am NOT for
I'm strongly opposed to that but we
don't have to see where we go with this
pandemic crisis I think there are a
couple other layers too though that I
want to mention Peter I think what we've
also seen are some terrible political
decisions that we are actually bearing
the consequences of and by that I mean
all these political decisions that were
made decades ago to offshore a lot of
our manufacturing I think have really
put us in a place where we understand
we're not in a good place and I'll just
highlight this Peter 97% of our
antibiotics are made in China
80% of the the materials used to create
drugs domestically are made in China
we've put ourselves in a very precarious
position and I think a national security
when you realize about 50% of the
American people are actually on some
form of antibiotics or drugs every day
this is a national security issue that I
think we need to re-examine it and do so
in a serious way and do as quickly as
possible
other more but you let's at the outset
that was a bipartisan initiative
administration's did it okay so let's
keep that in mind you know rich what do
you think about that because you know
when I look at the how it's impacting
our politics we now know what six point
six million people have applied for
unemployment benefits I mean that's the
real political issue here it's something
that it's very difficult for me to
fathom because I'm a historian by trade
and I know the history of the Great
Depression extremely well and when you
start looking at these job people the
number of people are finding themselves
suddenly out of work I mean the only
other parallel is the great depression
is we at least in a sense in how was
moving into it maybe not its depth okay
we're not there yet but things are
happening very fast and I think that
there will be a very strong political
reaction if something isn't done
unemployed people that had high
expectations only four weeks ago are
going to be really upset and that's why
we have politics to express our views go
ahead rich yeah I totally agree you know
the problem that we're seeing here is
that people just don't know what the
outcome is going to be the uncertainty
is really driving people crazy because
so
weeks were like all right things are
going great and then some weeks we
hearing we might be in quarantine and
locked down for four or five six months
and what's happening is that's really
raising the anxiety of people people are
don't know what to tell their children
they don't know what to tell that
families and and employers what about
employers you know I could understand if
an employer for a month can't get by
they did well they had they had a good
economy before this but what happens
when you get into the to three months of
no money coming in of still having to to
pay for services and and I'll be honest
with you a lot of these banks and these
lenders although they're gonna say oh
we're going to work with you after a
couple months they're gonna come and
they're gonna want their money and these
employers are gonna have no choice but
to lay everyone off they can have to dip
into their savings and to be honest we
need to figure something out now I
believe the lockdown is necessary
because there are people listen I'm
great maybe a few miles away from New
York City there are people that just
don't listen they just don't listen they
go outside and they're they're
contributing to the spread of this virus
so I understand the lockdown but we
really need to put our heads together
and and I don't want to see the
politicians do what they're doing now is
the narrative is switching
blame for this instead of saying let's
get out of this first and then we could
all get together and figure out what the
problem was
you know they going to go to you I mean
it's it's you know it's one of the
things I find really does pathetic is
this blame game right now I mean why
don't we just put that aside for just a
little while I mean because I'm
people stations and all that and then
you know it's either you know you know
three cheers for the White House or you
know it's time to burn the White House
down and its occupant okay that doesn't
move the needle for the six point six
million people that I just mentioned all
of these people that are bickering right
now it doesn't gonna be it's not gonna
matter the people that are unemployed
I can't go to university and it's like
it yeah all that bickering at the top is
gonna be just white noise for angry
people eventually so I mean I I know we
are in very partisan times but it
usually I was telling that before my
father was in the second world war and
he was a die-in the rule Republican but
in 1944 he voted for Franklin Roosevelt
because he said we have to stick
together and get through this amazing
struggle and I think dealing with this
pandemic and its outcome in what comes
in its wake is really is equivalent to
being in at war okay because millions of
people gonna feel that way your thoughts
here go ahead
well it's mean it's a war with an
invisible and a new right this is the
hardest thing about this pandemic and
how funny it takes a pandemic for most
of us to come together and and agree and
there's not much that we could disagree
on here and this uncertainty is
maddening particularly for women and I
want to bring up women here and women on
the panel in that you're not at okay
every say that I'm like women guests on
it and as you know we are in different
lines of work many of us have have spent
our the younger part of our lives our
20s going off and pursuing advanced
degrees education all that before
getting married and having children like
myself I'm in my mid-30s now but I got
married pretty late had kids pretty late
um by every measure but what it's done
and what's become painfully evident to
me before this pandemic is that American
society didn't know how to support the
modern working woman and now that
problem is gonna be compounded because
I'll just share my personal situation
for a moment my entire family is on the
front lines of this epidemic my husband
my mother my brother and my sister two
brother-in-law's and sister-in-laws are
all working in hospitals and clinics
right now what's that done to me as a
non MD as a non health care worker it's
put the onus back on me to keep my
family together and how to make sure my
two children not just fed but educated
every day make sure my husband's getting
what he needs make sure our home is safe
we're did taking the proper precautions
and doing everything that the CDC
mentioned that actually had led me to a
place that is making me more
conservative that I
ever been before and I don't think
that's a bad thing I think that's an
excellent thing because that's my home
man tourism we've been working people
that's that's the long and short of my
conservativism okay I mean I can agree
with progressives on all kinds of things
when it comes to family when it comes to
working people because that's what I
care about most okay you know Ned
unfortunately so much of what we hear
about the this pandemic and I will be
very blunt with you and people on cable
that have no idea what they're talking
about and and really just really
aggravate what's going on here I would
prefer to listen to experts and not what
some Reporter that says what the experts
said because they gotta get it wrong
more times than not and there in flaming
things and it's because of the occupant
in the White House I get why a lot of
people don't like him fine that's fine
okay but he's there and we're in a
crisis okay and I get the impression
that they they want the worst things to
happen because they it's makes them feel
good about themselves and about 2016 and
everything else and it I find it so
childish so juvenile and so destructive
go ahead and Ed yeah no I
Peter I do agree I mean obviously
there's no secret about me being a trump
supporter at the same time can we just
hit a pause button on this and and
realize we as Americans have to get
through this I mean pointed the 6.6
million Americans unemployed I mean they
I think we're just at the very cusp of
seeing some of the economic damage that
might result from this we have to figure
this out I said to this to you Peter
before we went live this is just the
first way we can't do this again in the
fall this would be absolutely
devastating to us economically if we try
to do is we've got to figure this out we
have to come together and figure it out
the thing that I would point out is this
and I think we can all agree on this
regardless of right or left I think the
Obama administration I think the Trump
administration were very poorly served
by the NIH and the CDC in regards to the
swine flu we had 10 years to prepare for
this Peter and I I want I want Trump to
put together a blue-ribbon panel after
we get through this to examine what our
burek
that's doing with literally tens of
millions of dollars for research and for
preparation we had ten years prepare and
I feel like we were caught short in our
preparations for this the American
people deserve better in regards to
funding a bureaucracy to prepare we're
going to I don't think we need to go
through this again jump in there I have
something to add there Peter twelve
years ago I was studying at the George
Washington University here in nearby
Washington DC I was studying there
School of Public Health and I mentioned
the University because we had so many
great lectures and professors who were
working in agencies like Department of
State and twelve years ago I could have
never happened
that a textbook case these crises he
that were literally textbook case into
twelve years ago we knew then there are
federal government was ill-prepared to
deal with something of this magnitude
and so I do agree with Ned there is that
everybody think when you served by these
Moffet agencies and so much bureaucratic
red tape that doesn't even let us get an
answer what if they what they've been
doing but I would say this I expected
more is I have said publicly I am
actually supporting Joe Biden in
November and that something changes and
I've been a lifelong Republican always
for Republican this is the first time I
voted for a Democrat and will be on the
in a general I have been a little
disappointed by his response he there
presumptive nominee he's been saying
that you know I'm going to convene some
experts so far just been criticisms on
Twitter and so it seems like the loudest
voices that are winning on the left or
people like Alexander Ocasio protest who
are who are proposing fundamentally
restructuring our economic system by
saying forgiveness forever for
everything these people I think really
with me data to act like adults I think
that maybe Trump and Biden should just
you know a presumptive nominee
previously they be campaigning and and
and marshal their resources together
show who is presidential here it won't
happen here rich let me touch it about a
little bit here how did we get to a
place like this I mean it seems like a
great deal of complacency that it can't
happen to us that's what happens to poor
people brown people all around the world
it never happens to us
and how did we get to that level of
complacency because net has also brought
up you know what really angers me and
it's angered me for years of off showing
all of these jobs now it's coming back
with a vengeance and you know we should
we should take we should bring back the
jobs and bring back that's good that's a
big project I just can't
to the level of complacency that it can
never happen to us because it is well
well I think number one and I've been
saying this way before this pandemic
happening and a lot of people have the
money in politics is a major problem
because people are filtering money
companies foreign companies they're
coming in and setting up other companies
setting up advocacy groups setting up
these these political action committees
which then filter money to politicians
so when you start to look at a
politician and what they say and you're
like why does this make no sense you
just follow the money and understand it
makes perfect sense it makes perfect
sense and we've got to duck to a place
of complacency because countries like
China have been dumping tons of money
into all these organizations they had a
ones who fund studies and you know what
happens when someone funds a study
obviously the studies always going to
come out in their favor right so so the
money in politics is the problem and a
complacency comes from the fact that if
you look at our politics today evening
today I mean I'm looking at Twitter much
we're just going crazy
you see AOC like the other guests that
mentioned they're starting to use this
as a way to usher in all those things as
they see we told you
capitalism is the problem see if we were
just this type of country or that type
of country that's a problem because
right now what we need to do is find a
solution to this okay and the
complacency comes from the fact that
politicians are too busy destroying each
other and the people are just standing
there going what's going on here well
I'm a bit generous I would probably
slightly rephrase it the the deep
political and ideological corruption of
our elites okay money for interest
foreign companies you know everybody
gets all wound up with Russia gable it's
a hoax okay but then you look at the
amazing amounts of money that China is
seated all through the American economy
in academia and and politician
everything like that I mean look at
Lindsey Graham Lindsey Graham suddenly
goes out on the limb for visas for for
Chinese I mean I love people I mean it's
kind of against the trend there but it
seems like you know that that's a
special interest
he's serving up you know and I'm Lindsey
Graham and I like him up every other day
okay the odd days I hate him okay but
he's a politician here we don't have to
speak to that because it looks like our
meets the first of all they didn't know
I was going to say they were caught off
guard know everybody anyone that was in
the know knew this could have how okay
and there was a 90% plus of our
antibiotics and other medicines are
outsourced from abroad okay I mean it's
you don't have to be a genius understand
that Wow we're at a pretty fragile
situation yeah like I mentioned earlier
I mean only in my mid-thirties and for
the greater part of my lifetime I've
been used to this this is business as
usual
it's to source things from other
countries what happened to American
greatness the manufacturing that we used
to have here the textile centers the Art
Center is places like Detroit and or you
would go for handmade furniture we're
used to getting it from every other part
of the world now we are no longer
looking inward and that's what I wanted
to say for the longest time in politics
I've been standing up and saying look
there's nothing wrong with being
conservative a thing it starts at home
it starts in the family and and right
now a great many American parents are
feeling that pain because guess what
mathematics is difficult these parents
are probably really frustrated by how
hard basic math is for them because we
haven't put the emphasis on education in
this country we've outsourced this we
let parents say that yeah let the
teachers teach what they teach but I
don't I don't have to do anything when
my kids come home that's where we have
gone wrong and that's where China and
India and Russia and other countries
have done better than us they have seen
our weaknesses and they've exploited
that and it's because there is a
greatness still here I've always
believed in it and and my parents came
here in the 70s and 71 and 80 to be free
to be exact my parents came here with
terminal degrees we take great issue
with anybody who jumps the line does it
illegally we believe you come here and
you could shoot something and be
competitive be innovative that's the
greatness of America but what is
happening in India right now with their
21-day lockdown why is it working out so
well over there police will chase people
with batons no matter how wealthy or
four you are if you leave your house
police are chasing you at the time that
didn't happen in the US because
Americans I just I don't think American
elites believe in America at all okay it
really makes me angry
because it's good to be the average
American that's gonna pay for their
their their their greed okay moral
attitudes I mean I'm very sick and tired
of it I'm tired of being nice to people
like that because there's no reason to
be talked about the Civil Liberties
issue of it because this is really one
of the hard ones okay now we all agree
we we have to be careful and we have to
respect the rules and regulations and
put out for our health okay and for the
health of others but the tendency is I
mean all during this during the
impeachment hoax and then we have this
we have the Patriot Act removed no
discussion no disco most Americans don't
even know about okay no real changes to
FISA okay because this is all going on
it's in the last page but these are
civil liberty issues that are so very
important because once the government
the state takes they very rarely give
back and I'm worrying they're taking a
lot right now go ahead yeah no I but I
want to really quickly address Peter and
I'll address this but but the previous
question is why were we caught unawares
why were we apathetic because of our
ruling class prioritizing their
interests and prioritizing the interests
of their corporate donors and I've been
very honest about this and very
outspoken about this but but juxtapose
the 6.6 million Americans that are
unemployed this week versus a 25 million
dollar pay raise for Congress a pay
raise for the FBI 25 million for the
Kennedy Center which by the way was
sitting on 140 million dollar endowment
they serve their own interests and when
you are practicing your own interest
you're not prioritizing the interests of
the American worker or the American
taxpayer saying it goes on vacation okay
just of liberties I mean the thing that
concerns me is we're seeing these things
even sitting here in Virginia now we're
on a June 10th lockdown what happens to
freedom of assembly what happen
to freedom of worship what happens to
all of these great freedoms in our First
Amendment at a certain point I as I've
been saying this is unsustainable we
have to have a better approach my
concern is like you said once the
government starts to encroach they very
rarely give back and you see some of
these things where the government is
working with Facebook with Google with
all of these people collecting personal
data to supposedly track the corona
vibes I understand that in the short
term but these things have to have a
hard stop and if they do not they will
continue on and encroach upon American
civil liberties you're even seeing
things Peter in Florida where they're
using drones which have the ability to
collect very personal data on
respiration heartbeat all of these
things to be able to track people to
make sure that they're not doing these
things that will help spread the virus
fine in the short term what does it mean
for the long term at some point you have
to say there will be a hard stop to
these actions or they'll continue join
and we all know that they will
yeah George Orwell's 1984 wasn't
designed as a user's manually it was
designed as a warning okay you know rich
how do we balance this here I mean I I
don't have the answer I've thought about
it a lot okay but but you know giving
easy and we're not necessarily getting
much security for it okay I mean I don't
get you know during wartime you you have
to you know look at Abraham Lincoln
probably the greatest president of the
United States like I ruled with an iron
fist okay you know a lot of people don't
know about me they know the mythology of
the man but he ruled very hard because
it was a danger to the Republican we
were in a civil war but it was given
back okay I don't see any guarantees
here even people talking about don't
worry we're gonna get back to normal
what is back to normal I don't get that
go ahead it's true it's a great question
and by the way I feel the same sentiment
towards Lincoln I think he's totally
misunderstood I think he was a great
president and you know what the Civil
War was something that was on a scale of
something that was seen now that
obviously we're not going to see that
amount of debt but the type of political
crisis it was is very similar and
certainly you know levels but what I
would say is this is that the civil
liberties are so important and but there
has to be a balance on what we see is
people
left there pulling it using this as a
way to to justify taking a lot of these
civil liberties you know they were they
were trying to here in New Jersey they
were trying to stop gun gun places from
doing gun sales saying it's not priority
but they were saying abortions are
priority so we see this like a double
standard here for civil liberties and it
should be flat across the board we
understand that people have to stay home
we understand that people shouldn't be
going out there spreading the virus but
we also shouldn't be taking their data
that's going to be sold to another
corporation that's probably a foreign
corporation that's gonna pick up all
that data and then start serving them
and serving a propaganda I made a
Twitter post here today saying hey look
I understand we have to save the economy
and we have to do all this stuff but
let's bear with the pain for a couple
more weeks and so we can start you know
trolled by like five or six would seem
to be propagandist Twitter pages saying
this is America's fault do this America
who is was wrong data once the blame
doesn't move the needle it doesn't help
anything doesn't do anything people that
have a political axe to grind I have I
wear my own ideological collars on my
sleeve all the time everybody knows that
but I'm willing to sit down to talk to
any reasonable person to move the needle
in the right direction really give you
the last word on the program how do you
how do you look at the issue of civil
liberties here because I mean we've gone
the u.s. has gone through a Civil War a
Great Depression you know we've gone
through a lot of things and we've been
able to keep it together and it seems to
me there's so many people willing just
to let it go because because of what
it's supposed to mean to them and their
their what I would say distorted vision
of history and their ideological
obsession it seems like they're willing
to give a lot away on a whim it's
they're relieved to be relieved of their
liberties go ahead marina well I'll say
this is that the words give me liberty
or give me death or have always been
really important to me but seems like
that crowd right now is suffering from
what people on the left and and really
across the political spectrum suffer
from is being the victims of fake news
people are not taking the time to
educate themselves and figure out really
first
what a lot of our elected leaders are
saying Senator Rand Paul for all of his
downfalls I think has warned about a lot
of this for a long time is are we okay
with a surveillance state like nad said
in the short term it's fine but what are
the long-term implications I over here
think that right now yes we are living
in a moment where we are facing the real
consequences of inaction at the federal
government level and that's not
acceptable anymore
today when I woke up I saw the number of
Americans that are perished has risen
over 5,000 there is something so
painfully wrong in this moment we are so
divided as a nation because we allow
ourselves to accept fake news as truth
that we are forgetting what our
underlying principles are in this
country and what matters with the
beautiful beautiful thing about America
is that we value each individual life
and that's what sets us apart from each
country in the world what makes you
wonderful and I really appreciate your
life story because it's immigrants and
the children of immigrants they tend to
love America more than I've written so
many people I'm sorry on the political
left
they hate the country they hate the
people and and that's adding to the
problems that we're having right now I
guess in reston birth em boy and in
percival and thanks to our viewers for
watching us here at RT see you next time
remember
crosstalk walls
[Music]
you